♪ ♪
>> Sean: AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
TONIGHT, WE START WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT TO ROBERT MUELLER
SET TO TEXT BY, IT CAN ALL
BACKFIRE AS WE PREDICTED
YESTERDAY, AMI DEMOCRATS, THE
MEDIA MOB, I WILL EXPLAIN
IN MY MONOLOGUE COMING UP.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE LAWRENCE IN
THE STREETS OF MIAMI.
ALSO, GREGG JARRETT WITH HIS TOP
NINE QUESTIONS FOR
ROBERT MUELLER, STRAIGHT AHEAD.
BUT FIRST, BIG BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT EXPOSED AND EVEN MORE
ANTI-TRUMP BIAS INSIDE
DEEP STATE.
WE HAVE THE STORY, THE REST OF
THE MEDIA MOB THEY WILL IGNORE,
AS USUAL, AS THEY CONTINUE TO
CLING, LIKE A LIFEBLOOD TO THEIR
LIVES, THEIR CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
I TOLD YOU THIS WAS ALL COMING,
THAT IT WAS ONE OF THE MISSING
PIECES TO THE ENTIRE PUZZLE.
WE NOW HAVE NEW DOCUMENTS
OBTAINED TODAY BY THE AMERICAN
CENTER FOR LAW AND JUSTICE, NOW
REPORTED ON BY "THE HILL"'S JOHN
SOLOMON COME UNDER VIABLE
EVIDENCE OF ANTI-TRUNK BIAS FROM
TOP OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS COME IN THIS CASE, THE
FORMER U.S. AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED NATIONS PEERED UNDER
OBAMA, SAMANTHA POWER.
PROOF OF SHEER POLITICAL PANIC
ABOUT WHAT WAS THE INCOMING
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BACK IN
2016, A FRENZY OF ACTIVITY.
REMEMBER, SAMANTHA POWER IS AT
THE CENTER OF WHAT WAS A DRASTIC
AND SHOCKING, AND FRANKLY
TROUBLING, INCREASE IN THE
UNMASKING BY TOP OBAMA OFFICIALS
IN 2016 OF TRUMP TRANSITION
MEMBERS, AND YES, PEOPLE IN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
A 350% INCREASE UNMASKING THE
NAMES, THE IDENTITIES, OF
AMERICANS, AND THESE REQUESTS,
INCLUDING HUNDREDS -- THE U.N.
AMBASSADOR?
WHY WAS THE U.N. AMBASSADOR
UNMASKING ANYBODY?
SHE DID NOT HAVE REGULAR
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING AND SPUDS
ABILITIES.
WHY?
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN AN AMERICAN IS
SPEAKING TO A FOREIGNER, AND THE
AMERICAN IS NOT UP TO ANY
NEFARIOUS ACTIVITIES, WHY WOULD
THE PROCEDURE, THE PROCESS, THE
MINIMIZATION, WHY WAS I NOT
BEING FOLLOWED?
USUALLY WHEN THEY WRITE AN    A
REPORT, THEY DON'T SAY WHO?
WHEN YOU UNMASK THE IDENTITY,
WHY DID THEY DO THAT, WHAT
POLITICAL REASON?
IT APPEARS BECAUSE THEY HATE
DONALD TRUMP I DIDN'T TRY TO
HIDE IT.
WHATEVER HAPPENED IN THIS
COUNTRY TO CIVIL RIGHTS, CIVIL
LIBERTIES, RIGHT TO PRIVACY,
MIRANDA RIGHTS, A CORNERSTONE OF
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC?
WE ALREADY KNOW THEY SPIED
REPEATEDLY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, WE KNOW THEY COMMITTED
PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON A FISA
COURT TO SPY ON AND HURT A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE SO HE
WOULD LOSE, THEN
PRESIDENT-ELECT, AND THEN
PRESIDENT, ALL BASED ON
POLITICAL, BOUGHT AND PAID FOR,
RUSSIAN LIES THAT THEY COULD NOT
VERIFY, BUT THEY LIED AND SAID
THEY DID, AND TRIED TO USE THOSE
LIES AS THE BASIS TO RIG AND
LATER UNDO AN ELECTION.
EXPOSING AMERICANS IDENTITIES
WHEN THEY SPY ON THEM WITHOUT A
WARRANT?
THAT IS ABUSE OF POWER.
THAT IS A DIRECT THREAT TO ALL
AMERICANS' CIVIL LIBERTIES.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN A 2016 EMAIL
FROM OBAMA'S U.N. AMBASSADOR ON
AN OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT ACCOUNT,
POWERS RIGHTS TO THE ARTISTIC
DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC THEATER
IN NEW YORK, SAYING "EXPLAIN OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT
WILL FLEETINGLY MAKE IT SEEM
RATIONAL, THOUGH MAYBE NOT AFTER
TRUMP AND SANDERS WIN
NEW HAMPSHIRE," SHOWING A CLEAR
ANIMUS, HATRED FOR THE
THEN-CANDIDATE.
IT GETS WORSE, EMAILS ALSO SHOW
APPARENT EFFORTS TO UNDERCUT THE
INCOMING ADMINISTRATION USING
THE MEDIA.
IN THE LATE 2016 EMAIL RESPONSE
TO UNIVISION'S JORGE RAMOS,
ABOUT AN EXIT INTERVIEW, POWER
RESPONDED "IF WE DO SOMETHING,
WE WILL MAKE IT GOOD.
PTSD IN RETREAT, TRUMP HAS
VANQUISHED IT."
OTHER MESSAGES SHOW EFFORTS TO
USE GOVERNMENT SPEECHES AND
EFFORTS TO PROMOTE THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION
CONSPIRACY, UNDERCUT TRUMP
POLICY AGENDA ITEMS.
WE REACHED OUT TO SAMANTHA POWER
FOR A COMMENT, HAVEN'T HEARD
BACK.